tell me the story quickly about it's 9
11 that's one of the worst time time
moments in u.s history yeah and uh
you were trying to you had to go back to
well i was i i'd flown up on 9 10 uh to
to do second unit on the second episode
the one with dan lauria the football
right right yeah and so uh
the next morning all hell broke list the
world completely turned upside down so i
was there and all day i was waiting to
be called to the set finally got called
to the set and they came to the to the
door of my dressing room and said uh
we're not going to get to you sorry
and i burst into tears another thing
that when they say on the page the she
bursts into tears i never really known
how to do that until that day when i
burst into tears in front of the poorest
sarah the pa i remember sarah yeah
yeah it's very sweet
so i burst into tears and then it didn't
look like they were going to get to it
any time soon so i called the office bob
guy
and said i would like to go home because
i was away from my family and i was
i thought well they're going to hit la
if they're going to hit la i want to be
home yeah so i just wanted to get home
this is i said if you're not going to
need me i'm going home there are no
flights so i took the car that i had
been renting and i drove home and i
stopped in reading that was my only stop
and i got home they called and they said
we need you tomorrow
i said you told me i could go home i was
like weeping i said i
why and then they said well if you're
not here we're gonna it's that kind of
stuff they started getting really nasty
about it and so i said well i'll i'll i
can't get there tomorrow because i can't
get a plane unless you want to charter a
flight for me
so i'm so mad
so michael said i'm coming with you so i
turned around the next morning we left
and drove drove all the way back so
somewhere between portland and seattle i
got this this weird melody in my head
it kept going over and over and over in
my head finally i said mile do i am i
making this up or is this a song an old
song that he said oh
i've never heard you you're making that
up he said let's put let's put lyrics to
it so we just said mommy and potatoes in
the paddy wagon i said okay but potato
has to be a girl it can't be just
potatoes oh okay and we wrote the whole
song in the car on the drive in the car
and we had nothing nothing's gonna
happen with this yes nothing's gonna
happen so we get get there and we finish
the song in fact i think i went to work
the next morning and he finished filling
it all in
and like
he didn't have he must have brought his
guitar he brought his guitar because he
always yes he had his guitar so he was
fooling around with it figuring it out
and he said you know i think chris will
might like this for a mighty win
chris guest because they were in the
process of writing all the songs for the
movie
so
uh
we we did we wrote that and then we we i
can't remember the
timeline but anyway chris asked michael
to write if he wanted to write this
signature song for mitch and mickey and
he said the only thing it has to have a
kiss in it
there's a kiss they whether they're
going to kiss or not at the end of the
rainbow and so michael said to me do you
want to write this song with me i have a
title already
kiss a kiss at the end of the rainbow i
said yeah
so i drank two glasses of wine that
night
he dressed
he smoked his
his friend
and we sat down and we wrote it
we we
mostly wrote the song and then we took
jimmy our beloved dog jimmy out for a
walk and finished writing the song
and then
took it to chris sang it for chris and
he said oh
it's beautiful but it's too it's it's a
real song it's it's too it's not
he didn't think it was going to be funny
enough
so we went home and wrote another song
called closer than tomorrow which is
another wonderful song but jamie lee
curtis happened to be there when we sang
it she said oh no that's the song it
should be a wonderful song it shouldn't
be funny it shouldn't it should be a
real love song
and we love that song because it's just
about us it's about our story and just
kind of how we we feel about one another
and um
it it and we were nominated for an
academy award for it i mean come on
really crazy come on because of all the
and that score should have been
nominated every song chris wanted every
song to be a different type of folk song
right
and that's what they did you know they
and eugene and catherine wrote stuff and
uh
cj vanston who's the the spinal tap guy
who does all their music for all their
movies um and traveled with them and
wigged unplugged
he wrote a c shanty and didn't have
lyrics so michael and i wrote the lyrics
for that jesus so i had three songs
represented three songs and you had
never written a song before really i'd
written stuff for the kids just stupid
stuff yeah